agriculture engages a significant
portion of the population in India and
around the world it is a seasonal
livelihood where Farm activities and
incomes VAR throughout the
year backyard poultry farming can
provide crucial incomes to over 70% of
rural households in India which amounts
to about 30 million
Farmers it is a cost effective easy to
manage practice for personal consumption
and a reliable secondary source of
livelihood by understanding the thermal
spatial and management requirements in
backyard poultry farming celco
Foundation has developed a Dr integrated
climate adaptive solution for tropical
wet and dry climates this solution was
implemented with farmers in Karnataka
India
is very important to note that the
domestication of poultry is due to major
factors of the environment climate
because they are homeotherms they adjust
their body temperature to the
environmental
temperatures since they are homeotherms
their body temperature is 105° uh
Fahrenheit and they are comfortable when
the temperature around 75° fit after the
broing is
over higher temperature causes stress
lower temperature also causes stress we
have to provide good sheds with cross
ventilation safety from the cats dogs
reptiles and also the cross ventilation
is very important because the birds have
to be kept stress
[Music]
free
[Applause]
foree fore
[Music]
GRE
for for
Birds need Optimum light for their
production and reproduction particularly
when there is light they tend to eat
more eat more grow more
[Music]
the cou solution creates a conducive
environment to practice backyard poultry
more efficiently leading to increased
production savings and higher income
farmers for
CCO foundation in partnership with the
agriculture Department of davanger
District in Karnataka replicated the
solution with over 80 farmers in 2023
and
2024 the solution was customized based
on recommendations from both Department
officials and farmers
[Music]
crucial secondary incomes through
backyard poultry sustained rural
economies it needs innovative solutions
to address informalities and
infrastructural gaps Dr integrated
energy efficient and climate adaptive
built environment solutions for
livelihoods can improve production and
income for farmers and micro
entrepreneurs conducive policies Finance
mechanisms capacity building and Market
linkages can strengthen the adoption of
these interventions
[Music]
Circo Foundation focuses on facilitating
and strengthening this ecosystem by
supporting the integration of these
Solutions and fostering sustainable
growth in rural communities
[Music]